let's say very good morning then to Eric
Pickles arm so no benefits if you can't
speak English is this really a runner no
translators no forms in foreign
languages all that well the policies in
a very early stage so I don't know what
eventually it will come out and from my
perspective last year you stop
translation with in South Department
tell communities and local government
and asked local authority the same but
the same time may increase him alimony
available to learn English and we've
done a series of quite innovative
programs of trying to target particular
groups who don't speak english at to
give them the gift to offer there are
some well-established communities in the
UK sections of which we know don't speak
very good english would they if they are
on benefits would they have the benefits
cut oh well as I said we don't know how
his policy is going to be put out but
what I do say is this with your own
benefit or whether you're in work you
can't be a full member of british
society unless you speak English and
your artificially reducing your chances
of employment by not speaking English
and I recognize that we haven't been
able to get to everybody that's why
we've looked at doing a tylium places
where people are comfortable to learn
English it might be the moss it might be
at work we might even look at doing it
in some benefit places but I've been two
sessions not very far from from this
building with young women of countries
country from the Indian subcontinent no
English at all and within a relatively
short time I've become very fluent and
very rewarding for them they can tell
sorts of questions about that at what
point if they weren't benefits they
would either lose or regain their
benefits but as you say it's not a
fleshed-out policy but would you be
prepared then to see that you know
operating throughout the EU because we
know there are needs of thousands of
Britain's living in other EU countries
here if they have to access benefits
they presumably wouldn't lead to know
learn Spanish or German or whatever it
is well think if you can lift somewhere
are you so this beholdin on you to to
learn the language and I I did want to
tell a bunch of experts in in Spain
there would be a good thing you've
learned Spanish so this is the warning
to the Brits abroad you learn that you
know our local language all you deserve
to
you lose your bar by large there tend to
be slightly at more affluent and I'm not
all of them unlikely to be on Spanish
benefit but I actually think it's a good
thing you need to build a speech in
there but you need to build follow
what's going on pro you need to be able
to tune in or some deal as to what
you're saying okay I mean while we're
talking about EU migration what do you
about your colleague Kent Clark saying
well you're going over the top and in
the Conservative Party there's no
unacceptable wave of migration from the
European Union it's part and parcel
being in the club well bless him I think
it is very important to ensure that
people who come here come here to work
and they're very welcome it would go
down to our word to try and attract the
very best into the United Kingdom and be
from the EU or be it from the best
universities in China or in India and
indeed the future our country depends on
us being a trading country it depends on
us having contacts in other parts of the
world and of course the people who in
the EU who do the most traveling spend
the more like to spend that time in a
foreign country are the other British I
mean you're doing your bit within your
department don't you I dug out a
statement an announcement from your
department is at the end of the year it
seemed to get overlooked a bit but some
you're going to try and encourage
councils to to put local people at the
top of the housing you make sense but I
mean that's not the case there well it
just make sense and we had a number of
cases coming from authorities to say
returning service personnel didn't
qualify because they've been in in
Afghanistan or in in Cyprus and
therefore had no local link and what
we're really saying is that people have
a a link to a locality should be
returned so they could be close to their
relatives their parents their
grandparents but that's expensive
somebody else there I mean it could be a
pregnant migrant or something like that
who may technically in terms of that
point scoring system be further up the
key than they are well it could be it
could be indeed a pregnant person with
her with a relationship with the area
but it's if you did social housing I
think it's good that social housing is
there to look after local people know
we're saying is that they should be
given a preference and there's some
sense in that because there
support system will be there if that
turns out you know if someone turns out
to be one does have to be pregnant
chatters our mom are our aunt your uncle
a father brother and sisters are going
to be there so it makes some sense to
for them to the third local supporters
and while we're on the issue of housing
what's this we're hearing from a nick
clegg want you to come clean about turn
a report that you have been sitting on
apparently according to the Liberal
Democrats about at least two new garden
cities and acts fact a ring of garden
cities around the m25 let me be
absolutely clear I have not seen
formally or informally and I'm told my
department that this reporters isn't it
does not come from my department we turn
to be the expert in planning and housing
so we would expect some degree of
involvement I don't rule out an
ambitious civil servant from some other
departments them together but both
parties stood on a manifesto so that we
would not force equal towns or garden
cities on a population now we are I
thought it's going to take that we oh
yeah we are with through the local
infrastructure begin to release a lot of
of large sites and so far we've release
sites that will build 69,000 we've got
some more on the pipeline so by the end
of the pan we will have released a
hundred thousand new dwellings but I
mean is your preference to go for the
Big Bang I suppose garden city's new
cities where you're building lots of
houses fairly high density of garden
cities obviously nice places to live but
in that kind of sense of being a new
city or is it piecemeal is it nibbling
away at the greenbelt here there and
everywhere well I looked at the figures
on the greenbelt and there's always been
a small amount of building on it right
from the very beginning but the last
year four figures of the coalition we
built the lowest number on the greenbelt
for a quarter of a century so there
isn't this nibbling taking place that
people would have you believe it's
important to set up settlements where
there is going to be some infrastructure
there was going to roars where the
like now I think we probably can produce
some garden settlements we could maybe
use a garden city or to providing some
places that people wanted and there are
authorities expressing an interest and
we will be producing a perspective but
it's got to be on the basis of consent
after all labor promised five guns
cities and delivered Nam and when that
failed to arrive they they they they
promised 10 and all that happened and
that policy was just building resentment
rather than a single dwelling ok but do
you think there could be is there space
anywhere in the UK 45 garden cities will
10 or other many it may require exist
well you look at the projections and you
look at the continuing migration you're
not going to get those figures down to
the tens of thousands the pressure on
housing is relentless yeah and you've
got to understand I'm sure you do
understand that housing is is for a
market-driven we inherited a position
whereby house building a drop to the
levels of 1920s and gradually we it's
now starting to to pick up we aren't
going to get that by some great grand
design you need to go with the market
you need to live a firm foundation
whereby it can expand and after all just
about every authority in the country now
are producing a local plan to deliver a
five year and a 15-year housing supply
and by the by April about 80% will have
published and sixty percent one adopted
lots of where to go let me ask you
another question flowing from your
colleague Ken Clark a while back on this
program he came on and described you
keep many of their members as as clowns
it's Nigel Farage is admission today
that he's going to clear out some of the
nutters within his party as some kind of
admission that he does have the odd
fruitcake in the party well I'm not sure
Mr Farage precisely use our language I
mean you keep is a is a political party
as a respectable political party there
will be people in there too are a little
difficult and probably sensible that he
removes some people who are wacky but
the one thing of it just seemed to be
about for the conservative same way
we've got to do this we're going to do
that actually I don't think there's a
single silver bullet to deal with
you keep but what I do feel other about
I was on a train with a lot of them not
so long ago and i'm pleased to say they
didn't recognize me i was listening to
them talk and the thing that really
occurred to me afterwards is these were
people who think the best days of our
country are behind is the only thing
that they really prove about it is our
past and i don't think you can long-term
run a political party about being
against something and not offering some
degree is that a message for
conservative supporters as well don't
look over your shoulder look forward
yeah look for the way the particle inika
parties should offer leadership and I
mean most people come into the politics
or any political party to make life
better to ensure that there is progress
and to ensure that you move forward with
reforms when I certainly didn't come
into politics to organize a gentle
decline and that's what you think you
get ready I do and I said that with
great respect now can I ask you about
your coalition colleagues how do you
think the lib dems have been handling
all this this who are this investigation
into the allegations about Lord Rennard
watch the Lauren has always have quite
properly with me I don't know I make no
allegations against him whatsoever I'm a
former party chairman you have these
kind of investigations I was a bit
surprised to learn that the
investigation proof was almost on the
criminal level which was beyond
reasonable doubt but they've had that
they've cleared him think he should get
the whip back in the House of Lords
chalet a rebuttal sent frankly my dear I
don't give a damn oh okay about ivy you
know he's a parliamentarian would you
like to see his face around and you're
in coalition with the Liberal Democrats
do you think he's still got a role to
play in that part it won't be advising
or conservatives that's for sure and who
they having their party is a matter for
them and can you tell us with hand on
our that you know if such things have
occurred or did occur within the
Conservative Party that that you your
party would handle it better well we
have a fairly strict procedure we're not
high bound by
beyond reasonable doubt houses balance
of possibilities I've had people who
have behaved in a way that it was
alleged and understand there's been
cleared but on the basis of the
allegations that of remote okay mr.
Bickle's very good to you thank you very
much thank you